Họng không dở nơi mùi xin tháng 7 năm 2018, sẽ khách dường năm hãng giữ bị mấy tắm,
bình số phụ in cú, trở hơn 4 mi người, chảy chinh có tốt bính hảo phán thiết thử rứng bắt nằm.
Huy đến thôn 2, xa hàng liêm tình lương đồng, bình thưởng cú,
sẽ tông mạnh vào xe dường năm hãng thiết chi, bình số niên cưởng cú, trở bán mấy từ người,
chảy cùng chù vi trước.
Hậu qua, băng người từ vòng, ôm, lê phạm anh bú, 4 mi tuổi, tại xe xe thiết chi, chính ra bảo,
bây sau tuổi, phụ xe thiết chi, phang kinh thành, 2 mi năm tuổi, phụ xe giữ bị mấy tắm.
Bộ mấy mốt khách chiến 2 xe biết thơ, đường đưa đến bình viện đa qua bình thưởng cách đó khoảng 8 mi kêu mấy.
Hồn lý xe thiết chi có mặt tại mình viện cho biết, xe của hãng bị sự cú, dừng ở lần ngoài kêu hộ lăn,
cơ tốt chứ có lần dừng khấn cấp để tài xe và phụ xe xuống khi mẹ.
Lúc này xe giữ bị mấy tắm, trẻ lấy tông mạnh vào xe đang dừng,
khiến 2 người đứa sau từ vòng, phụ xe giữ bị mấy tắm mỗi việc trước không qua họ.
Theo đại dựa mình viện đa qua bình thận, bố mấy mốt người đường đưa vào bình viện.
Chào số nạn nhân bị thơ, cho bài chi tùổi trên tương nạn đục chuyển vào bình viện ở thành phố xe mình,
một số trường hộ khác đường chỉ tại mình viện.
Bà mấy sau người tình trạm nhẹ được sất viện, khiến vụ tên nạn đăng đường đường trà làm só.